how can you be toxic to a toxic person
that must be really bad how bad is she
she must have been nuts
but basically mike perry recently
because he's out in florida right now
right
of course this happened in texas though
oh happened in texas so
if you look at this clip in this video
i'll show i'll put it into the actual
video
let's go i'll stay here what do you want
[Music]
i'll just wait here bro don't worry
about it
no y'all wanna cry y'all calling the
cops i'll straight because if i leave
you your friends no
i have a side i don't have to go
anywhere
again tell them to bring the kids are
you bringing the cops
because if i leave him did you touch me
hey
uh you see the first girl walk out and
the first girl that walks out of this
bar
is actually his girlfriend and then the
other who's the other girl that looks
like she got something it was her friend
was a friend or sister a friend cousin
or bartender i don't know what it is but
she's trying to basically calm this
whole situation down
now mike perry is a fighter he is a pro
ufc fighter and whatever happened in
that situation
basically a couple of people or two or
three people were accusing mike perry of
hitting them first right whatever that
situation was
but mike perry is sitting there
screaming at them saying you didn't put
your hands on me you didn't put your
hands on me
and there's another man who was who was
intervening it was an older gentleman
let's say he was quite large quite large
and bald right here
yes let's say he's very highly coveted
susceptible
and he was in the open and basically he
wasn't wearing a mask and he was not
wearing a mask
and so mike perry he's talking he's like
well i don't want to walk away from this
situation because if i do you guys are
going to say a story i have to stay here
and defend myself and tell mine
now i'm not saying this is how he said
it he was screaming this at the top of
his lungs
and he was saying end bombs and stuff
like that he was dropping down yeah you
know what i'm saying and he said like i
want to be here with the police
and said white guy decided to make fun
of how mike perry was speaking and he
goes
to the police and you know how you know
how sometimes people of the less
uh melatonin in their skin do yeah you
know they're very condescending very
condescending
or you can call the police to a [ __ ]
professional fighter not only
tattoos on his face not only a
professional fighter a [ __ ] maniac
yeah
a crazy person yep and so he actually
comes up to mike and he said he's gonna
[ __ ] whoop his ass or something to
that extent yeah he actually threatens
mike perry
i would never ever in my life say
anything to a person that looks like
that
sorry sir what's funny is i when i watch
that video
like i could see how hood mike is
because like
i've seen people do this to like real
life right when that guy goes like
oh i'm gonna call the police and then
mike looks at him and he just goes
just stares at everything he's like beat
yo ass
you know he was he was so he was so
shocked that this guy made fun he was
like
man i'll beat your fat ass like dude
not even a full set this is but that's
beat joe [ __ ]
that's the [ __ ] thing bro this
[ __ ] old dude has the audacity to
talk
to go to a guy that has tattoos on his
face who's
buff as [ __ ] who's scary as [ __ ]
and and and try to fight this dude mike
perry looks like a gargoyle
bro like a pit bull and a gargoyle
[ __ ] each other and then mike perry
was born
that's not an insult i'm saying that's
just what he looks like and this guy has
a nerve to try to go up to him and he
goes up to mike perry
it looks like he shoves him looks like
he pushes him first bro
for me from what it looked like to me he
put his hands up and it looks like he
like
it looks like he like touched his face
yeah like he literally shoved mike
perry's face and then as soon as he
touched his face
the guy disappears from the camera yeah
he drops like a [ __ ] sack of potatoes
and honestly that's what you [ __ ] get
bro if you're gonna say i'm gonna call
the cops
you sit back you call the cops exactly
there's no reason why you should be
going to a grown-ass [ __ ] man
and putting your hands on him and not
expecting for somebody to punch in the
[ __ ] head
i'm sure that guy got up too like oh my
god yeah yeah
he was bitching about it when he was
trying to start a fight with somebody
yeah and stop it bro we're not even
talking about the story that happened
before because nobody knows what
happened there besides the people at
that bar
what we're just saying is when you look
at a person that
looks like he was born inside of a
prison right
you leave them alone especially if you
don't scrap yourself yeah
that dude looked like he was a cast
member of the office yeah like what the
[ __ ] were you looking like
a minute uh a walmart version of kevin
and queen combined what are you doing
dude when i watch that video like if if
no one even put
the title like oh mike perry punched
somebody i would have known
just when just when he goes oh i'm gonna
call the police
and i see michael and i just see mike
look at him and go
beat your fat ass i'm like oh he's about
to [ __ ] soccer
and that's exactly what happened that's
hey like i said i don't know what
happened so say if mike was in there
actually
punching a [ __ ] ton of people and [ __ ]
before then it's a little different but
even on that i'm like
you [ __ ] pushed him first bro
what do you expect you you pushed him
first you're gonna [ __ ] with the guy
that punched a bunch of people
yeah exactly you better be ready to
[ __ ] throw down bro and that's the
thing is like people
and we talk about this all the time like
if you're gonna get in someone's face
and talk all this [ __ ]
you better be ready for to get knocked
out or to knock somebody out i don't
understand why he that man couldn't
assess the situation
it's like dude mike perry looks like he
has seven different types of hepatitis
like he will [ __ ] kill you like i
don't understand that [ __ ] like why
would you do that people don't think
[ __ ] like that is gonna happen to him
until it does yeah i'll tell you this
one story so uh i got kicked out of this
one 24 hours because i sucked at doing
the face super [ __ ]
christ dude this was like this was a
[ __ ] a long did you hit him with a
barbell
no it was that basketball court that's
something he would do no i would not
random pencil comes out yeah
and uh this is during the time i used to
play ball a lot right this is before i
blew out my [ __ ] knees my ankle
things were all good it was all gravy
so we're playing ball and at this time i
remember specifically because i was uh
trying to lose a lot of weight i was
weight training a lot and this is when
like circuit training was super big
right
just like a lot of compound lifts yeah i
just worked out a [ __ ] ton
and then afterwards i would try to burn
it off by a few more calories just by
playing ball because i enjoyed it a lot
so we're at the courts we're playing i'm
not that great